there is nothing profound in talking
about your genitals all the time
there is nothing deep about obsessing
over our bodies and our sensations and
our lowest appetites
that's what little children do
adults are supposed to get past that
we're supposed to grow up we're supposed
to rise above merely chasing our own
pleasure
and think about things outside of
ourselves
reality
duty responsibility
we're supposed to tame our will and
bring it into accord with our intellect
we are supposed to cultivate desires
that rise above the level of the libido
that is how you cultivate a dynamic
inner life
read a book
find a hobby
do
anything that takes your mind off of
yourself for even five minutes
i don't mean to sound like a scold i
know i do but i i don't mean to
i don't even mean to place myself above
the epidemic levels of narcissism that
are plaguing our culture i'm not above
it we're in it we live at a time that
especially encourages and exacerbates
this culture of narcissism
we live in an increasingly digital world
that insulates us from physical reality
it's no coincidence that most of the
most prominent prominent detransitioners
these are the people who had fallen
under the sway of gender ideology and
saw the light came out on the other side
to reality it's no coincidence that many
of them describe falling into it through
social media
social media which revolve around
self-obsession and which permit an
unprecedented degree of self deception
and illusion
the social media platforms that have
replaced the town square are designed to
addict you to likes to the affirmation
of others
these platforms are funded by
advertising that for the first time in
history is tailored specifically for you
individually
everything you say
every place you visit every spot on the
screen where your eye happens to glance
we'll build a digital profile of you
that will allow corporations to know you
better than you know yourself
to cater to your every whim whether
those whims are edifying or destructive
every whim that they think will make you
give them more of your time and money
the increasingly immersive and
sophisticated fantasy lands that we all
inhabit have created what we call the
mental health crisis
this is one of the few issues where the
left and the right agree
we don't agree on very much these days
we both agree
we are in the throes of a mental health
crisis
depression anxiety suicide are all up
more than one in eight americans over
the age of 18 regularly takes
antidepressant drugs
even kids are taking them
one in 29 young americans aged 12 to 19
regularly takes antidepressant drugs
suicide rates have reached record highs
in the united states including among
children and that was true even before
the covet lockdowns which have only
exacerbated the problem
the situation is extremely dangerous
america is cracking up
we are aware of our psychological
problems and because of that we flock to
psychologists in our private lives and
in the public square
some of the most influential celebrities
of our time and of the last 100 years
have been psychologists
unfortunately though the therapeutic
approach does not seem to be working
i suspect this is because the
therapeutic approach taken in isolation
without reference to philosophy or
religion
can only serve to compound the problem
because psychology also is all about
us
we can find consolation through
philosophy and salvation through
religion
through psychology we find only
ourselves
at the root of the mental health crisis
lie two more fundamental crises one
spiritual and one religious
one spiritual i'm sorry and one
political sometimes you'll hear people
say i'm not religious but i'm spiritual
and very often what that means is i'm
not interested in god or the truth but i
am really interested in me so you know
hear my theories about these things
those are the two crises spiritually we
no longer remember what we are
so we alternate between on the one hand
pretending that we're purely physical
meat puppet chemical bags
whose purpose is nothing but to feel
pleasure and to avoid pain because our
very existence is nothing but a freak
accident of nature that's on the one
hand
on the other hand
we pretend that we're not physical at
all
that our bodies have absolutely nothing
to do with our true selves
our true self which is entirely
metaphysical such that some guy's true
and authentic self might really be a
little girl trapped inside a hulking
man's body
obviously these two views don't jive we
go back and forth between them
sometimes within the same conversations
our culture flits between these extremes
we have discarded the traditional idea
that man is body soul and spirit
inextricably linked at least
on this earth
we have discarded that view precisely
because it's traditional and it's 2022
man and we can't believe things that
people used to believe that's crazy we
have to believe all those new things
until we solve this spiritual crisis
until we remember at the very least what
we actually are
men made in the image and likeness of
god
we will never solve the mental health
crisis for the simple reason that we
won't even be able to say what the mind
is
the second problem is a political crisis
as our narcissistic culture increasingly
insists upon the affirmation of our
subjective delusions
we find it more and more difficult to
communicate
because communication requires an agreed
upon sense of objective reality
the left is driving the abandonment of
reality
look no further than justice anthony
kennedy that romantic poet from the
supreme court who in a court decision
that we hope will be overruled tomorrow
planned parenthood be casey
justice kennedy said that at the heart
of liberty lies the right to define our
own concept of existence
of the mystery of life
wow man isn't that something else boy oh
boy
it's like a
hippie slam poetry or something it comes
down in our own juris prudence
the right is not blameless either though
in recent decades the right has
retreated from its traditional stance of
moral clarity and adopted the
wishy-washy platitudes of very online
libertarians you do you do whatever you
want just don't make me pay for it that
sort of thing
we are now finding the disastrous
consequences of that political
ambivalence all around us
sexual chaos social collapse and a
pervasive sense of malaise
every time we think that we have reached
the bottom of that slippery slope what
happens
we just keep on slipping don't we we
never seem to get to the bottom we get
lower and lower and lower in the span of
about 10 years we have gone from
democrats saying that marriage is a
sacred bond between a man and a woman to
some republican saying that we need to
trans the kids
actual sitting republican governors
you do you is not working
it is time to call it like it is again
a healthy culture is humble
accepting of natural limits
and deferential to the wisdom of the
ages
a narcissistic culture celebrates pride
to escape the madness and the misery
we need not think less of ourselves
but we certainly must think of ourselves
less